[Music]
foreign
what are the differences between the two
groups of animal-based Transformers that
is between the Beavers Dinobots and the
rise of the Beast maximals let's get
into it firstly let's take a look at
both of their Origins the maximals were
originally stated to be direct
descendants of the Autobots that was
stranded on Earth since the prehistoric
times after the Great War on Cybertron
the exact origins of the maximals has
never been fully explained nor has the
timeline of their emergence as a faction
been told to us but it has been said
that they have been a distinct group of
Transformers for thousands or maybe even
a few million years they might as well
be the first of the Transformers to land
on Earth in the rebooted timeline
the Dinobots on the other hand are a
group who can transform into dinosaurs
or at least robots that resemble them
while they carry the autobot Insignia to
say that they are a swarm of animalistic
Roots is an understatement they were
held as prizes or trophies on board
lockdowns ship until the Autobots
dismantled that piece of the ship to
rescue Optimus Prime thereby freeing
them as well before assuming authority
over them optimists had to face their
Commander Grimlock these dynabots are
presumably millions of years old and are
Primal able to transform into the
extinct dinosaurs of the Cretaceous
Period
so what are the maximals that are to be
seen in the new movie Rise of the bees
well first among equals is Optimus
primal who is their leader and the Heart
of the group able to change from a robot
into a giant gorilla then we have the
fast and Nimble cheetah who takes the
form of a cheetah and then there is the
air razor Transformer who is a nurturing
and strong female Transformer able to
take the form of a gigantic flying
Raptor a falcon to be specific and
lastly there's rhinops who is both the
brains and the brute strength of the
group and as his name suggests he takes
the form of a gigantic rhinoceros in
their robot modes they are intelligent
and calm individuals with their own
unique robot forms now what other
dynabots that are seen in the live
action beavers movies again as first
amongst equals we have their leader and
the most powerful of the group which is
Grimlock an animalistic semi-sentient
Beast of a robot that takes the form of
a Tyrannosaurus Rex then next we have
scone who is also a giant even bigger
than Grimlock he transforms into a
Spinosaurus then as the air force of
their group we have strafe who takes the
form of a gigantic pterodactyl or
Pteranodon with two heads instead of
just one and lastly we have slug who
just like rhinox is the brute force of
the group and takes the form of a
Triceratops the dinosaur equivalent of a
rhinoceros in their robot modes they
look like the Knights of iacon seen in
the last night but way bigger now going
to the most important part of the video
there are size differences and
comparison
since Optimus Prime in the Bumblebee
movie was shorter than the Beavers
version standing around 6.7 to 7.3
meters or 22 to 24 feet tall Optimus
primal at his beast mode would also be
around the same height as seen in their
confrontation in the trailer in the
forest so Optimus primal will be around
7.6 meters or 25 feet at the most the
next one cheetor was around twice the
height of the Camaro which would put him
at 3 to 3.6 meters or 10 to 12 feet tall
in beast mode rhinox doesn't have a
reference point so it's kinda hard but
since he is the muscle of the group I
would say he would be around 6 meters or
20 feet tall but he is longer and more
bulkier twice that of cheetor aerys
seems to have a big wingspan and maybe
at an estimate that we estimate around
18 to 21 meters or 60 to 70 feet wide
all in all medium-sized Transformers in
Beast modes
now what about the dynabots Grimlock has
an officially stated size of 84 feet
tall or 25.6 meters that is in his robot
mode and not the T-Rex form but I'm
betting he'll be around 60 feet or 18
meters tall in Direct's beast mode
scone is a bit taller at 87 feet tall or
26.5 meters in robot mode and in
Spinosaurus form he would be taller than
Grimlock due to his spine at the back
slug is 71 feet or 21.3 meters tall and
in his Triceratops mode he would be
around 40 feet or 12 meters tall now
lastly we have strafe who is the
smallest of the group standing at 57
feet tall or 17.3 meters in robot form
and even that he is big compared to the
others and in beast mode he has a
wingspan of over 100 to 120 feet wide or
30 to 36 meters all in all gigantic
Transformers in size both in normal
robot modes and in Beast forms
now let's finally take a look at their
powers and abilities and assess which
are more powerful the dynabots or the
maximals well the dynabots take the cake
with sheer size and brute strength able
to annihilate several Decepticons with
ease in their appearance in Hong Kong
they were also deemed to be too
dangerous as foes to be tackled by
Megatron and his Decepticons in The Last
Knight as robots they have melee weapons
but that's about it and that is their
main disadvantage their lack of ranged
Weaponry aside from grimlock's fire
breath the maximals however are
intelligent both in robot and in Beast
modes and they do have ranged weapons in
their robot modes but in Beast forms it
is only air razor that Sports the same
fire breath as Grimlock but as a more
focused beam so it's mainly strength
versus intelligence here so it seems
like a tie but there is one more Factor
their gigantic size the dynabots will
win the fight just by this
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam